A roast is the hardest
thing to do in comedy.
I compare it to our Olympics.
I really feel like there's
nothing else to compare it to.
You have to go, as soon
as I asked to do the roast
I start writing jokes,
and then you have to
start taking those jokes out
and then I have to go from club to club
and just tell the people watching,
I'm like, imagine Rob Lowe is here,
just for the sake of things.
I'm about to say a lot
of mean things about him.
Picture him here laughing,
and then you get laughs, but it's like
you can't ever really know
how it's gonna do in the room.
There's no way to tell.
And so, it's so much preparation
and then you finally do it
and luckily it's always a great crowd
and they're ready for
it and it's gone well,
but the first time doing
it, I was terrified
and I always for the past three roasts,
the three that I've done,
I always get a point of
utter exhaustion beforehand
because I've trained so hard
and that night it just feels
so good doing it and being done
because you just never know.
It's one of the only things in comedy
that you can't really prepare for
because it's such a unique performance.
I'm kind of not surprised,
but it's interesting
to hear that you test,
or have the ability to
go test the jokes out,
which makes perfect sense.
Why wouldn't you?
You're in front of the mic
and you're doing your thing anyway,
because for me, I'm not
a professional at it,
I had never tested one of
those jokes that I got.
So I'm literally, this is the
first time I'm telling it,
the first time anybody's hearing.
I have no idea if people are gonna think
it's too mean, not mean enough, whatever,
and it's all live and it's
in front of everybody.
I know!
I always worry about the
stars during these roasts
because as a comedian, Jeff Ross, me,
and usually the other couple comics,
we're all at the clubs all
night doing our roast sets,
and then we think about the actors
that are on the dais,
and I'm like, they're just gonna wing it.
But the thing is, they always kill!
You guys always do well.
You have one rehearsal,
but you're professionals
so you always do well,
but it is funny that I feel the need
to go out and run the set like 60 times.
That's crazy!
Like honestly Rob, every
single time I do a roast
I am so run down because I'm
doing like five sets a night,
having all these sheets of paper,
scratching out jokes, rewriting
them, reorganizing them.
I hired a writer's assistant last year.
I hired writers.
I had a writers' room last year.
I'm not even joking.
What?
It was nuts.
I lost money on it, no joke.
But it is the biggest opportunity
for a comedian to make a
splash and to really be seen.
It's like we don't have
The Tonight Show anymore
with Johnny Carson.
We don't have the same.
It's just the best platform
for a comedian to make it,
so I work my tail off on it
and every year I tell my friends,
remind me never to do one of these again
because I'm losing my mind
and I hate this process,
and then I do it and I'm like,
oh my god, that was the
best night of my life.
I feel like they're pregnancies.
I'm always like, I don't
want to do this again!
And then I'm holding my baby
and I'm like, I love it,
I want to have another.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't have kids,
but I compare it to that.